et comme tous les jeudis c'est la
chronique et co présentée par elsa
destine à 10 rebonds soir en soir
catherine ce soir on parle de on va
parler de l'intérim parce que je vous
parlais donc la semaine dernière de la
au sein des chiffres de l'emploi on y
reviendra en détail dans filets qu un le
magazine économique de la rédaction mais
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de me consacrer
donc à l'intérim parce que les premiers
frappés par cette hausse du chômage ce
sont les intérimaires alors bonsoir jean
mars où l'ordre bonsoir vous êtes
responsable du développement au fonds
d'action sociale du travail temporaire
le faste qui est une structure qui est
assez méconnue si je peux dire je me
suis penché un petit peu en détail sur
son fonctionnement mais tout d'abord est
ce que vous vous ressentez dans votre
quotidien dans votre travail cette
conjoncture cette mauvaise conjoncture
de la façon par l'impact les
intérimaires alors bien sûr on recense 7
cette crise qui est installé depuis
quelques temps maintenant les salariés
intérimaires ont la possibilité
d'accéder à un certain nombre de
services lorsqu'ils sont en mission ou
pour accéder à des missions telles que
le service de garde d'enfants à domicile
à l'appel que des soutiens de taille
vous le ressentez vraiment sur l'hectare
alors sur la dictée on a depuis
effectivement quelques mois moins de
sollicitations qu'auparavant puisque il
est difficile aujourd'hui d'accéder à
des missions et donc pour bénéficier de
nos services il faut être en mission
pour la plupart du de nos services
hormis ce qui facilite l'accès mission
envoyée depuis quelques mois vous pouvez
date est la variable ou sa magie depuis
le début de l'année
donc pour appuyer vos propos nous sommes
allés demander à des saint quentinois un
petit peu comment ils ressentent et le
marché de l'emploi au niveau de
l'intérim
mon contrat s'est terminé le 31 août moi
donc
j'ai besoin de retrouver vite un autre
emploi
quand on sort effectivement de cette
agence on me dit qu'il ya pas grand
chose quoi mais l'espoir fait vivre
jusqu'à présent fait il ya oui
effectivement il ya une baisse en fait
j'ai des amis qui travaillent qui sont
en fait tu es ils sont déjà inscrits à
l'intérim et ils ont de moins en moins
d'offres le camp faire beaucoup il ya
des offres ou mais il ya moins d'offres
disant ça si je peux me permettre la
moindre par rapport à
2,3 auparavant maintenant de jour
d'aujourd'hui on est obligé d'avoir des
plusieurs agences d'intérim oui c'est
sûr que là moi je suis recherché en
communication aimons la dame m'a dit que
ça allait être difficile sur cinquante
ans que donc c'est vrai que c'est je
pense que ça va être difficile mais bon
micro-trottoir a donc été réalisée
devant une agence en intérim à saint
quentin en yvelines alors on voit ces
intérimaires qui ont de moins en moins
de travail vous aux phases votre
activité a diminué à peu près de 15%
depuis le début de l'année votre
activité est ce que vous pensez que ce
chiffre va continuer à descendre c'est
difficile à dire mais c'est vrai que les
prévisions sont plutôt pessimistes
maintenant
personne n'a de boule de cristal en la
matière donc il faut penser qu'il ya des
secteurs qui sont plus touchés que
d'autres on entendrait cette dame
parlait de la communication du secteur
de la communication est ce que vous vous
sentez il y avait surtout des métiers en
fait davantage touchées que d'autres et
c'est vrai que certains intérimaires ont
la chance aujourd'hui d'être sur des
métiers où il ya encore de l'emploi
dans les métiers du tertiaire par
exemple certains métiers avec une
technicité qui peut être encore très
demandés
alors voir venir maintenant au faste en
détail nous avons assisté à une réunion
d'information vous parlais tout à
l'heure des services qu'offre le faste
on va voir ça en détail reportage
le monde de l'intérim souffre parfois
d'une image de précarité et pourtant une
structure propose de nombreux services
pour faciliter le quotidien des
intérimaires le fonds d'action sociale
du travail temporaire qui organise
régulièrement des réunions d'information
à la cité des métiers de trappes
mutuelle aides à la mobilité ou encore
garde d'enfants les services sont
multiples exemple avec le logement au
niveau du logement si quelqu'un donc un
intérimaire doit déménager et que le
propriétaire donc est réticent on m'a
des 600 heures de missions en fait on
peut se porter garant pendant toute la
durée du bail donc pour l'intérimaire on
peut également avancer sa caution dès la
première heure l'émission j'ai toujours
travaillé en intérim tous les avantages
que 1 à tel honneur poule peuvent
bénéficier de
de l'intérim je connaissais pas ça bien
avant je suis venu découvrir les
avantages proposés par le fasse tout
simplement parce que dans mon parcours
professionnel il est possible que je
fasse de l'intérim et donc j'ai anticipé
il ya certainement certaines
propositions week qui m'intéressent rond
comme la mutuelle par exemple prochaine
réunion d'information du faste le 19
octobre à 14 heures à la cité des
métiers de trappes en 2011 le faste à
délivrer 85000 prestation est mobilisé
20 millions d'euros
jean-marc soulondre on le voyait dans le
reportage le monsieur qui témoigne dit
qu'il ne connaissait pas les services du
faste et pourtant il est intérimaire
depuis une trentaine d'années est ce que
ça vous étonne pas vraiment
en fait on fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
informer les salariés intérimaires il
faut savoir que parmi les intérimaires
il y en a un certain nombre qui sont de
passage dans l'intérim et donc il faut
faire des efforts très récurrent pour se
faire connaître c'est à dire aller dans
les agences exactement exactement alors
les agences ont aussi disposer de
l'information
nous avons un site internet également
qui est accessible et puis le bouche à
oreille aussi fonctionne beaucoup et
puis le fait de nous avoir invités ici
aussi pu passer
de mutuelle ça vous proposez aussi un
service de mutuelle tout en lien avec
on se repose les services d'une mutuelle
à des prix très intéressants dégressif
en fonction de l'ancienneté en travail
temporaire en fonction des ressources de
la personne et ça permet donc aux
intérimaires et à leurs conjoints et
leurs enfants également de pouvoir se
couvrir et de bénéficier d'une mutuelle
tout au long de l'année y compris
pendant la période d'interdiction
bénéficiait il faut avoir travaillé un
minimum d'heures alors pas pour la
mutuelle pour la mutuelle de la première
heure de mission on peut bénéficier
d'une complémentaire santé pour le
logement effectivement il faut 600
heures de missions ça correspond à
quatre mois pour la garde d'enfants dès
la première heure de mission bien sûr
voir quand on n'a pas de mission pour
bénéficier d'un
d'un emploi on peut faire garder son
enfant et accéder à un travail c'est
très souple alors comment fonctionne le
faste comment est ce que vous êtes
finances et comment est ce que vous
arrivez à proposer tous ses services à
des prix très raisonnables
le fastt financé par l'ensemble des
entreprises de travail temporaire c'est
un le faste est né d'un accord de
branche et donc c'est un dispositif
national
c'est comme cotisation tout à fait sûr
la succube prix sur la masse salariale
est-ce que donc vous avez une obligation
de résultat est ce que parents ont cité
les résultats à la fin du reportage le
nom de personne que vous avez pu aider
est-ce que vous avez une obligation de
résultat on a une obligation de moyens
déjà et on a une obligation de résultat
bien sûr de qualité de service apportée
puisque les salariés intérimaires ont
besoin de service réactif il faut
pouvoir réagir vite et donc pour la
garde d'enfants par exemple le service
de location de voitures on peut mettre
en place ces services-là en moins de 48
heures très efficace et sur votre site
internet on trouve un web documentaire
que j'ai trouvé très bien fait qui suit
le parcours de plusieurs intérimaires
des parcours croisés on va regarder un
extrait ensemble
depuis environ une vingtaine d'années
entre coupé de cdd ou de cdi je fais de
l'intérêt l'intérim je dirais que c'est
très riche c'est très riche en
connaissances humaines c'est très riche
en compétences professionnelles
en diversité aussi
maintenant ce n'est pas par choix c'est
vraiment par rapport au marché au marché
d'aujourd'hui moi j'ai besoin d'un
logement assez rapidement et donc j'ai
demandé
conseil à mon agence d'intérim qui m'a
dit bah il ya le faste ce tu veux ils
peuvent aider à trouver un logement même
si le propriétaire ne s'en est pas servi
moi je vais présenter les papiers du
faste comme quand il se porter caution
si une seule agence comme le faste se
porte garant pour moi ça veut dire aussi
que j'étais revenu régulier donc lui
cela va rassurer v quand j'ai commencé
ce poste-là d'assistante de direction
sur ce projet là effectivement j'ai fait
appel aux fastes et à la garde d'enfant
puisque je devais quitter mon domicile
très tôt l' le phasme a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup aidé ça c'est très
positif
et pour terminer jean marc ce lot de
risques vous pouvez donner des exemples
de tarifs par exemple si on veut louer
une voiture de suivre donc sur la
location de voitures les intérimaires
peuvent bénéficier d'un véhicule pour 10
euros par jour
on propose également pour les personnes
qui n'ont pas le permis d'accéder à des
locations de deux roues vélos pour deux
euros par jour et sur la garde d'enfants
le coup et d'un euro de leur forme à
table alors on rappelle la prochaine
réunion d'information du faste qui aura
lieu à la cité des métiers de trappes le
19 octobre à 14h et donc vous pourrez
avoir toutes les informations
nécessaires pour faire appel aux
services du fast merci beaucoup jean
marx le d'être venu emplettes aux hyper
disent on va parler maintenant un autre
exactement commerçants de
voisins-le-bretonneux qu'on suit depuis
le début depuis le tout début de
l'ouverture de leur magasin et ça marche
très fort voilà la boutique a ouvert en
2000 doha exactement c'est une boutique
qui sent bon donc ils font du café du
thé et puis des produits artisanaux ils
ont reçu plusieurs récompenses dont
meilleur torréfacteur de france en 2010
et plus la dernière en date ils ont reçu
un mercure d'or qui a été attribuée
chaque année qui attribue chaque année
par les chambres de commerce dans la
catégorie création et reprise
d'entreprise rencontre avec la
propriétaire des lieux
le titre de meilleur torréfacteur de
france nous l'avons partager avec notre
clientèle puisque sa récompense notre
savoir-faire notre technicité
et c'est quelque chose que nous
réalisons
devant nos clients en permanence au
magasin alors que le mercure d'or ou le
trophée de la création d'entreprise sont
des titres qui
récompense plus la qualité de gestion
l'innovation et dynamisme à gérer
l'entreprise c'est quelque chose que
l'on peut mettre en avant en cas de
difficultés ou ça peut être un levier
supplémentaire
pour avancer dans le développement de
l'entreprise
l'obtention de ces différentes
récompenses
c'est le fruit d'un investissement
personnel important
c'est le fruit d'un temps passé et
d'une passion aussi d'un intérêt pour ce
que l'on fait on y met beaucoup de notre
personne c'est peut-être ça le secret
le sacré effectivement remettre de sa
personne ça c'est sûr c'est le secret
allez pour finir cette chronique est qu
alice un chiffre chiffre de la semaine
exactement un chiffre qui n'est pas très
bon 246 c'est le nombre de créations
d'entreprises dans les yvelines au
deuxième trimestre 2012 selon l'insee un
chiffre donc en légère baisse puisqu'il
était de 347 au premier trimestre avec
danses et une belle mais cinq ans ok
merci beaucoup a dit smith à ta
chronique et qu on vous retrouve dans le
magazine fait l'écho quick a diffusé en
ce moment ce moment on parle de la
guerre des centres commerciaux et puis
on vous retrouvera aussi demain vendredi
pour le 7-8 week-end merci alice elle
rien à voir avec l'économie c'est du
sport cette fois du foot quand le petit
rencontre le grand le club de foot
d'elancourt a signé un contrat de
partenariat avec l' aj auxerre a rien
que cela
les jeunes joueurs élan courtois peuvent
rêver de ligue 1 l'aj auxerre arrive à
l'eau et celle en cours l'équipe de guy
roux a signé un partenariat avec le club
yvelinois un département où l'aja
n'avait pas encore de relais pour ces
détections le souhait de la gym c'est
d'essayer a bien sûr de pouvoir faire
les meilleurs détection dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et plus
rapidement possible donc nous avons une
stratégie d'observation
et sur le niveau des yvelines nous
avions ce manque est donc plus la
demande est notre souhait voilà le
mariage se fait comme ça les deux clubs
axent leur travail sur la formation des
jeunes et les éducateurs de l'eau essais
pourront bénéficier de l'expérience au
cerveau c'est de s'appuyer sur une
connaissance sur une technique à pinaire
dont on ne peut pas avoir nous mêmes
donc si on s'appuie sur vraiment des
gens qui sont professionnels une
expérience de la formation d'éducateurs
confirmé qu'ils vont forcément apporter
à nos joueurs et à nos éducateurs bien
sûr parce que ça passera d'abord par la
profession demande aux éducateurs une
façon à ce que nos éducateurs puisse
encore mieux s'occuper de nos enfants
les formateurs bourguignons se rendront
quatre à cinq fois par saison et long
cours pour conseiller et échanger avec
les éducateurs élan courtois et les
responsables de l' os et pourront
assister en échange à des entraînements
de la jirs les deux clubs sont liés pour
trois saisons